Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
George Washington,
who lived from 1732 to 1799 was a founding father of the United States as
America's first commander,
first president,
and much more.
He would begin his career in the British army and would end up later in life
having played a major role in the foundation of the United States.
In this video,
we're going to look at 10 tips and pieces of advice from Washington,
but he left us the route,
his many endeavors that led to his successes within them.
So let's get to it.
Number 10 it is far better to be alone than to be in bad company.
Washington was a man who placed emphasis on duty and honor and preferred very
much to surround himself with people of that nature as well.
Washington felt that it would be far better to stand alone than to associate
with a nefarious or crooked group.
Number nine,
it is better to offer no excuse than a bad one.
Very much like number 10 this quote reflects Washington's nature as well.
Washington had his priorities straight and sought to fulfill his
responsibilities and obligations.
Likewise is someone who not only lead,
but in many ways created an army.
He expected the same from his subordinates,
valued their honesty and was not interested in unwarranted excuses for their
mistakes.
Number eight,
there is nothing which can better deserve your patronage than the promotion of
Science and literature.
Knowledge is in every country the surest basis of public happiness.
This quote reflects a trend among the founding fathers,
which you may have noticed an emphasis on education.
The most effective means to strengthen your nation,
empower it,
defend it,
grow it,
et Cetera,
is to arm the people with knowledge and Washington.
Hear claims that it is one of the greatest things you can do for your country.
Number seven,
worry is the interest paid by those who borrow trouble.
Washington was a straightforward,
orderly and practical person,
especially for rebel,
as was hinted at with number 10 he didn't tend to associate with the wrong crowd
or wander into the wrong direction.
However,
Washington did in fact find himself in trouble many times throughout his life,
even if it were in his eyes,
morally acceptable.
And so this quote may be from experience.
Number six,
we should not look back unless it is to derive useful lessons from past errors
and for the purpose of profiting by dearly Bot experience.
Washington believed that the past was useful,
not just the lessons of history but of one's own life.
Washington had military and political experience prior to the revolution from
which she drew heavily.
For example.
However,
one should not dwell in the past,
especially not a general or president.
We should make decisions in the presence and plan for the future,
not be held back by our past.
Number five,
if the freedom of speech has taken away than dumb and silent,
we may be led like sheep to the slaughter.
Washington,
like many of the founding fathers believed that freedom to say whatever you
wanted was a requisite of being a free person.
If our speech were to be censored and if opinions,
especially opinions that society found disagreeable were silenced,
then there would be few to speak out against injustice and organize against it.
Number four experience teaches us that it is much easier to prevent an enemy
from posting themselves than it is to dislodge them after they have got
possession.
Perhaps this can be seen as a quote referring to the battlefield as the American
struggle to dislodge the British from their country.
However,
it can be taken a number of ways and essentially boils down to avoiding native
people situations or anything of the like in your life before they become a
regular feature because removing those things is much harder than preventing
against them.
Number three,
true friendship is a plant of slow growth and must undergo and withstand the
shocks of adversity before it is entitled to the appellation.
Washington knew many people,
worked with many people,
saw many of the same people every day,
in fact,
but for him to consider someone,
a friend,
they had to earn it and Washington suggests that policy for everyone,
a true friendship has to withstand struggles,
overcome problems and display traits like loyalty and respect before those
things are displayed.
The friendship is not exactly certain and Washington's eyes.
Number two,
to be prepared for war is one of the most effective means of preserving peace.
To live in peace is the desire of all good people.
However,
one should not expect that life to be easily obtained.
The world is a very unfriendly place and self interested people.
Lurk everywhere piece must be defended not only on a national level but on a
personal level and only people who can defend their right to live peacefully.
We'll maintain it.
Number one,
labor to keep alive and your breasts.
That little spark of celestial fire called conscience Washington believes
strongly in maintaining a sense of integrity,
moral character,
and of course as he said,
a conscience.
These traits were in his eyes,
some of the most important that one could possess and to work to maintain them
was likewise,
one of the most important things you could do as you go about your life.
These traits are a very large part of how you are defined as a person.
These were only some of the quotes that Washington left us.
I would encourage you to check out more of what he had to say to support the
creation of more videos like these linked to our patrion can be found in the
description.
Any donation would be used to improve the channel.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.